I'll forego resumes and welcome to are
you looking for love well then you're in
luck
no I'm not available there's someone out
there for all of us bros but sometimes
you need a little bit of help so I found
this website that shows pictures taken
from a Russian dating website I'm gonna
recreate them for you so here we go
hi I did it all by myself don't worry I
don't bite
oh hey there I didn't see your leg I was
busy reading The Wall Street and licking
a banana it's one of my favorite hobbies
click on my profile to find out more
now let me excuse me I have to continue
it's my banana some call me Romeo and
this call me please no Mario don't want
to do this
who thought this was a good idea
oh hey I see that I think we should make
up a topic we should dates as you can
see I have great experience in cleaning
and murdering people
Anna my name is Sandra and I like to
think in the shower and also like a no
fist come baby birds what if you were
this fish right now just think of all
the possibilities I know two places
that's not a commission and one of them
is intubation this might seem like a
fishy situation but if you come here the
waters will be all clear
I found Nemo now you need to find me
hi-yah get off that car wasn't that
beautiful of a step it like this video
if it may be turned on just a little bit
come on just a little bit and thank you
for leaving a comment
this one is reversed thanks for being a
bro here it comes